hi I'm Wolfgang Puck and I gonna show
you what I will be cooking for the
Oscars well I'm gonna show you how to
make my Sivas in puff pastry with a
little chive butter it's really simple
we do it for the Oscars every year and
people just love it
you know for the Oscars we cook for 1600
people so we cannot cook everything to
order it would take too long but with
the fish and puff pastry we can make it
in the morning and then have 40 or 50 of
these fishes ready and we can cut them
into small portions and we have 4 or 500
pieces of fish ready to go what I like
about it is I can do it in advance so
nobody has to do it at the last second
and but it's great because of the puff
pastry it stays really hot inside we
make about 50 of these fishes even
bigger one and this won't just slice it
and serve it with the sauce and
everybody gonna get a hot fish the
moment people get out of the theater
they are all really hungry so when they
come up we have a big sushi bar roll bar
and everything outside with champagne
and wine and cocktails and everything so
people can get a bite and then when
people go inside the room as soon as
they sit down somewhere
you have waiter coming with trays of
food all on small plate now in the old
time it was a more formal setting
everybody had their place cards but I
said this is not a fun party because
everybody had to sit already for four
hours in the theater so when they are
out they want to mingle with people so
now I know if spirit becomes or Clint
Eastwood comes or some other director
comes I sit them all in the same area as
a more loungy feel and we serve now
everything in small pie everybody can
eat but instead of eating one big dish
you actually can eat 10 different sites
so you get a small plate of the fish in
puff pastry you get a small lamb chops
or you'll get a small baked potato with
some caviar
I'm gonna show you how I make my famous
chicken pot pie with black truffles
everybody raves about it I love to see
some of the people like Denzel
Washington or cleaned is Laura Murray
score
see or some of the people I know for 40
years when they're always asked to see
me they say Oh wolf is here we know
we're gonna get great food and I
remember powers risin telling me a few
weeks ago she said you know I don't care
what you cook for the Oscar just make me
my chicken pot pie
Prince Albert came one year after the
Oscars and he said I wish you would open
a restaurant in Monte Carlo and make the
same chicken potpie you made for the
Oscars
we started making that maybe eight years
ago or so every year I order like
Shirley pounds of black truffles from
France it's just the end of the season
the end of February beginning of March
we order lots of caviar and we make
tortellini or pasta with black truffles
one year when we still had the whole
fancy dinner when it was more formal we
made it for everybody and it was the
first time everybody got hot food but I
think it has become such a popular dish
they're gonna show you how to make my
salmon with pesto noodles healthy and
delicious in the middle of the 90s big
board of governors asked me to cater the
governor's board which at that time was
downtown at the Shrine Auditorium but it
was the first time that everybody
actually stayed for dinner because they
knew I was cooking and most of the movie
people most of the movie stars direct
the producers come to our restaurant so
they know the quality of the food we
serve so then they said you have to do
it every year so we started that 23
years ago one year Michael Caine came to
the Oscars one of our first Oscar
parties the next day he invited his
whole family to Spago and says Wolfgang
I want exactly the same thing I had last
night at the dinner party after the
Oscars and that we made him the same
dinner and he said almost as good as at
the Oscars I said we are you won an
Oscar that's why we always do also
healthy food you know food with no meat
in a vegetarian food so we might do for
example a tomato risotto make it totally
vegan we use a vegetable stock and we
use tomato sauce which we make ourselves
folded in without parmesan and butter
just add more tomatoes in it's nice and
creamy and we
taystee we have a lot of vegan dishes
also vegetarian dishes I have six people
on doing vegan dishes the salmon with
the pesto and vegetable noodles has
become very popular people think oh I
wanna eat healthy I wanna eat something
good so this is a perfect dish I'm gonna
make the most delicious Cabernet braised
short ribs every movie stars will love
it I think we make certain different
dishes so there's something for
everybody if you want a baked potato
recovery or a chicken pot pie or a bug
UB whatever it is we have it for you
when we do the menu for the Academy
Awards we're gonna have part of it it's
comfort food and part of it is
innovation place short trips is really
comfort food the chicken pot pie is
really comfort food so when people
didn't eat all day then at the end of
the evening by 10 o'clock at night
everybody is so hungry so to have real
comfort food feels really good
we also pass around our smoked salmon
Oscars our mini burgers our sliders all
kind of different pizzas there are so
many different dishes then you can eat
for an hour two hours whatever you want
but what it's exciting instead of having
one big plate
you can choose so many different on last
year we made surgery dishes basically
made like 15,000 plates everybody has
their favorite like steven spielberg he
loves our braised short ribs with a
little polenta we make some new things
always too this year we got for example
200 pounds of beef from the Miyazaki
Prefecture in Japan which really has the
best value of beef in the world but a
lot of things are traditional like our
chicken potpie and our fish and buffets
they will make it every year we also
make 5,000 chocolate Oscars which we
paint in gold so people can take them
home if the
win or lose we give everybody an Oscar
for me presentation is very important
because we always eat with our eyes
first
[Music]
this is a dish oscar-worthy as a matter
of fact is better than most of the
movies oh yes
[Music]